hey leute hallo ich bin der christlich
freue mich wahnsinnig heute haben wir zu
sein
willkommen zum einem neuen seminar
aschermittwochs komiker werden ehen
unter fünf minuten hering muss man das
denn lernen aber hallo
gerade sie welche gerade sie immer nur
die gleichen 23 miesen stotter witze das
reicht auf die dauer dicht ja sie
brauchen ein breiteres repertoire auch
ein bisschen politisch werden die feine
klinge führen
oder sie machen es wieder andy und
schreiben alte witze aus der funkuhr ab
der sozi ist eigentlich grundsätzlich
nicht dumm
er hat nur viel pech beim nachdenken
haut der suche spricht beim nachdenken
weil die doof sind die sozis verstehen
sie die sind ja so kompliziert war der
gar nicht hering
jetzt mal nicht so arrogant freundchen
von dem steuer können sie wirklich noch
was lernen also jetzt natürlich nicht
über humor aber übers buckeln über
schleimen hier jahrelang warschauer doch
der kleine streber der in jeder
einstellung dem seehofer aus der linken
schulter wächst wie so ein forum und
jetzt kommt der hammer der horst ist als
scheidender ministerpräsident quasi noch
warm der selber noch gar nicht im amt da
der scheuer hat sich eine neue wird
schulter gesucht um so was die fotos zu
finden wie den animus normalerweise 200
euro bezahlen
[Gelächter]
wo kam der pool her wo jetzt auf und
lernen aschermittwoch das heißt vor
allem den politischen gegner ordentlich
abwarten
bei der sprachlosigkeit die wir mit
amerika haben wäre hofreiter bestens
geeignet gewesen mit donald am zumindest
über frisuren zu diskutieren liebe
freunde waren beide in der logo frisur
und der hofreiter wunderbare
alltagsbeobachtungen ich verstehe das
überhaupt nicht was hat denn bitte die
haarfrisur vom hofreiter mit tram margot
jetzt reden sie noch nicht ständig die
gags das war pures kommen die gold und
seit wann hat humor was mit logik zu tun
humor das ist auch das ist da es muss da
muss auch nicht alles immer permanent
sinn machen
das ist die wahre spd nicht ich spiele
strich spd die spiegelfechtereien
betreibt sondern die spd die fracht wie
viel spiegeleier würde denn am teller
haben wir sorgen dafür dass es ihrem
teller krieg bot das ist doch
hoffnungslos mit ihnen ich fasse es
nicht sie ostwestfälische spaßbremse
meine güte worüber können sie denn
lachen ist eine gute frage ehring ich
fand es gab am kompletten aschermittwoch
tatsächlich nur einen richtig geilen
geld und er kam jetzt kommt ausgerechnet
von olaf scholz ihr allemal anschnallen
die neue bundesregierung hat also einen
guten start
also dem verstehe ich jetzt wieder nicht
[Applaus]